?
JOINING ME NOW K.T. McFARLAND
FORMER DEPUTY NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND AUTHOR OF
REVOLUTION.
PETE HEGSETH IS "FOX & FRIENDS
WEEKEND" CO-HOST AND HOST OF
MODERN WARRIORS ON FOX NATION.
YOU HAVE GOT TO GO SEE THAT
K.T., I HAVE GOT TO GO TO YOU,
FIRST.
BECAUSE THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
NOT GETTING ENOUGH COVERAGE.
IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE MOVING THE COLD WAR
ONLINE NOW.
SO WHAT IS THE RESPONSE GOING TO
BE FROM THE U.S.?
>> LOOK, I JUST WANT TO
COMPLIMENT YOU ON YOUR OPENING
STATEMENT.
YOU WERE SPOT ON BECAUSE ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID WAS TO HAVE
AMERICAN ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
WHICH DROVE DOWN THE PRICE OF
OIL AND NATURAL GAS AND MEANT
RUSSIA'S ONLY WAY OF MAKING
MONEY EVAL VAN FOR RATED.
RUSSIA WAS BROKE.
THE WAY WE WON THE COLD WAR WAS
BANKRUPTING RUSSIA.
THE WAY TRUMP HAD AMERICA FIRST
POLICY IS BANKRUPTING RUSSIA.
WHAT SHOULD WE DO NOW THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT THING WE COULD DO
IF WE WANT TO PUT VLADIMIR PUTIN
IN A BAD PLACE WOULD BE TO GO
AFTER HIS CYBER CAPABILITIES AND
GO AFTER HIS ECONOMY.
BY, AGAIN, HAVING AMERICA BE
ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
>> Lawrence: PETE HEGSETH,
THANKS FOR BEING WITH ME, MY
FRIEND.
150 ATTACKS JUST LAST WEEK
WORLDWIDE FROM THESE HACKERS AND
THERE'S A STATEMENT ACTUALLY,
THIS IS THE KREMLIN RESPONDING
TO RIOTERS.
HE SAID THEY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION ON THE CYBERATTACK
AND MICROSOFT NEEDS TO ANSWER
MORE QUESTIONS INCLUDING HOW THE
ATTACK IS LINKED TO RUSSIA.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> YOU CAN HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS BUT THERE IS NO DOUBT
THE KREMLIN WAS AWARE AND LIKELY
BEHIND IT THAT NOTHING HAPPENED
IN MOSCOW WITHOUT ULTIMATELY THE
BLEGGINGS OF THE GOVERNMENT AT
LEAST KNOWLEDGE OF IT.
AS YOU ACKNOWLEDGED.
K.T. IS WRITE RUSSIA IS A GAS
STATION WITH A FLAG.
WHEN YOU CUT OFF THEIR ENERGY
CAPABILITIES, YOU CRIPPLE THEM.
WHEN YOU INCREASE SANCTIONS AS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION DID,
YOU MAKE THEM MORE VULNERABLE.
AND WHEN YOU SUPPLY ACTUAL
WEAPONS INSTEAD OF BLANKETS, TO
THEIR ADVERSARIES, YOU ARE ABLE
TO BLOCK THEM.
I MEAN, REMEMBER WHEN BARACK
OBAMA IN 2012 SAID TO MITT
ROMNEY IN THE 1980s CALLED AND
THEY WANT THEIR FOREIGN POLICY
BACK IN THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
EXPLOITED RUSSIA WHEN THEY THINK
IT'S POLITICALLY ADVANTAGEOUS TO
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA, AGAINST
TRUMP.
BUT WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN AT THE
HELM, THEY HAVE ALLOWED VLADIMIR
PUTIN TO EXPAND HIS INFLUENCE
AND EXPAND WHAT HE WANTS TO BE
IS THE RESTORATION OF THE SOVIET
UNION.
THAT IS ULTIMATE LID HIS GOAL.
HE SAID IT OUTRIGHT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NO TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX TO ACTUALLY FIGHT BACK.
WILL WE RESPOND?
INFERIOR ADVERSARIES GO TO THE
TACTICS THAT CAN WORK FOR THEM
BASED ON THEIR CAPABILITIES.
CYBER IS WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN
THINKS IS HE USE BECAUSE HE
DOESN'T BELIEVE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL FIGHT BACK.
AND, THUS FAR, HE HAS BEEN
RIGHT, UNFORTUNATELY.
>> Lawrence: SO I WANT TO STAY
WITH PETE FOR A SECOND BECAUSE I
THINK YOU HIT ON A COUPLE GOOD
POINTS THERE.
ONE IS I WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WORDS AND
ACTIONS.
BECAUSE BACK WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT, THERE WAS A LOT
OF I WANT TO WORK WITH RUSSIA,
MEANWHILE HE IS LITERALLY
TEARING THEM APART, POLICY-WISE.
NOW, YOU GOT JOE BIDEN THAT'S
TALKING TOUGH, TALKING THE REAL
BIG GAME.
BUT POLICY IS REALLY NOT
REFLECTING THAT.
SO, WHAT IS THE STRATEGY THERE?
>> Pete: SPEAKING LOUDLY BUT
CARRYING A LITTLE STICK HAS
NEVER BEEN THE APPROACH THAT YOU
WANT TO TAKE.
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AS K.T. KNOWS
BETTER THAN ANYBODY, WAS DERIDED
BY HIS CRITICS FOR SAYING HE IS
TRYING TO DISMANTLE NATO WHEN
THE ONLY THING HE DID
REINVIGORATING IT.
MEMBER STATES THAT THEY HAD TO
PAY UP FOR THEIR OWN DEFENSE.
YOU CAN'T JUST STAND IN THE
BACKS ON THE AMERICAN MILITARY
FOR THE NEXT 50 YEARS AS WELL.
SO PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS WILLING
TO ENGAGE BECAUSE HE RECOGNIZED
THERE IS OTHER PLACES WE COULD
CONSTRUCTIVELY POTENTIALLY WORK
WITH THE RUSSIANS BUT HE KNEW
ALL ALONG THAT THERE AN
ADVERSARY TO YOU HAVE TO STARE
DOWN TOE TO TOE.
>> Lawrence: THEY WANTED A FREE
RIDE AND HE WANTED THEM TO SHARE
THE RESPONSIBILITY.
I THINK THAT'S PRETTY
REASONABLE.
K.T., WHAT SHOULD THE RESPONSE
BE BEFORE THIS CONVENTION?
HE DOESN'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME
AND HE CAN'T BE WEAK SO WHAT
SHOULD HE DO?
>> WELL, HE WON'T DO IT BUT WHAT
HE SHOULDN'T DO LAWRENCE IS GO
PUTIN AND SAY OKAY, SOLAR WINDS
HACK, THE COLONIAL PIPELINE
HACK, THE MICROSOFT HACK, YOU
SAY YOU HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
IT?
WE DON'T BELIEVE YOU.
IN FACT, WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
ACTION TO DEFEND OURSELVES AND
TO HAVE THE DETERRENCE WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST
YOUR CAPABILITIES, AND, GUESS
WHAT?
UNLESS YOU PROVE TO US THAT YOU
ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE, WE ASSUME
YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE.
>> Pete: YES.
>> Lawrence: PETE, I HAVE GOT TO
ASK YOU, YOU WERE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD, SERVED US
HONORABLY.
WHY ISN'T THERE MORE INVESTMENT
FOR CYBER DEFENSE?
WHERE ARE WE GOING WRONG AS A
COUNTRY?
THIS STUNT SEEM LIKE WE'RE DOING
ALL WE CAN DO.
>> WELL, WE DO HAVE SOME
CAPABILITIES THAT WE SHOULD BE
USING TO HIT BACK AT VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND THE RUSSIANS RIGHT
NOW.
WE SHOULD BE.
MORE THAN COMMENSURATE WITH WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE.
LIKE ISRAEL DOES TO THE IRANIAN
NUCLEAR CAPABILITIES DO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO AND WHERE WE NEED TO
DO IT.
THE INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX GOOD AT
BUILDING CONVENTIONAL WEAPONS.
A LOT OF MONEY IN CONVENTIONAL
WEAPONS AND ULTIMATELY THAT'S
WITH WHERE A LOT OF OUR
RESOURCES GO.
RIGHTFULLY SO.
WE CAN'T IGNORE THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE.
THEY HAVE LITERAL GLOBAL
AMBITIONS WHERE VLADIMIR PUTIN
IS TRYING TO EXPAND HIS FEAR OF
INFLUENCE.
CYBER IS WHERE OUR ENEMIES IS
GOING TO TRY TO HIT US.
THEY REALIZE WE ARE VULNERABLE
AND BETTER DOUBLE DOWN
INVESTMENT THERE WE ARE GOING TO
PAY THE PRICE.
>> Lawrence: I SEE WHAT YOU SAID
THERE YOU DIDN'T SAY WE COULDN'T
BUT WE ARE NOT.
WE DO HAVE THE CAPABILITIES WE
ARE JUST NOT DOING IT ANYWAY.
>> Pete: UNLEASHING.
>> Lawrence: THANK YOU K.T. AND
PETE.
DON'T FORGET TO CATCH PETE'S NEW
EPISODE OF MODERN WARRIOR
REFLECTIONS AVAILABLE NOW ON FOX
NATION.
IF YOU ARE A VETERAN OR AN
ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY, FOX NATION
IS OFFERING YOU A FREE YEAR ON
THE PLATFORM.
JU